Transcriber: Lujain Elmallah
المدقّق: Mohamed Salem
السلام عليكم.
تعرفوا شو هاد.
بلاستيك بس مش البلاستيك البتعرفوا.
أريدكم أن تبحر معي
إلى غرفة طالبة في جامعة الأزهر
تفتحوا الباب، تبدو للوهلة الأولى خالية،
لكن مهلا
ثمة فتاة عند الزاوية
تنظر لي أعلى محدقة بالسقف.
وفي عيونها ترى الحيرة والتردد.
قصتها سوف تحاكي مشاعرك.
قد تجد نفسك في الجزء الأول
أو بقلب الحديث أو آخره،
لكنك حتما ستجد نفسك
سأقولها من أجلي و اجلك.
أنا رنا أبو ظريفة أبصرت
نور الحياة بعام ألفين
وصنعت أول مكبر للصوت ذو جودة عالية
في عمر الأربع سنوات ليسمع كل العالم صوتي،
مهلا، نحن لسنا في اليابان، نحن في غزة
صنعته من خلال قصة قارورة ماء
بمصراتة جرح يدي.
كنت حادة الذكاء و أحصل
على علامات عالية، لزلت.
في الصف الرابع أتتني الكثير
من الأسئلة المعتادة.
كيف ذلك ؟ ماذا تأكلين يا رنا؟ ماذا تشربين
فلحقت أن أكثر من عصير الليمون،
قررت أن أشكل البيزنس الخاص بي
من خلال بيع ليمون شجرتنه لصديقاتي
قائلة لهم إنه ليمون خاص بعائلتنا،
يطور من ذكائي مطور بالمختبر
يحصل على علامات عالية
عشرة من عشرة مع ليمون الشجرة.
ليس الغريب أنني نجحت في البيع،  لكن الغريب
أنهن فعلا حصلن على علامات أعلى،
وهنا تعلمت درسا للحياة أننا لا نحتاج
ليمون لننجح، بل نحتاج للدافع
و الإيمان بأنفسنا بأننا نستطيع.
حينها حققت إيرادات إلى أن علمت أمي الأمر
و وابختني، واعتذرت من صديقاتي
وردت إليهن نقودهم ، وأخبرتها بكل
بساطة أنني لم أفعل أي شيء خاطئ،
فقد قمت بتسويق جيد لفوائد الليمون الذي
نأكله ونشرب عصيره دون أن ندرك فوائده
أهن من يوم ردودي.
أما بالنسبة للرحلة التي غيرت حياتي
فكانت تحدي القراءة العربي،
هذا التحدي الذي أطلقه سمو الشيخ الفاضل
محمد بن راشد آل مكتوم،
فقرأت أكثر من مئة كتاب خلال عام واحد،
وكتبت عن هذه التجربة الرائعة
في هذا البيت الشعري
ما كنت أنكر في قلبي قط
فضلكم من تحدي القراءة.
كتبنا بداية النصر بعض المعارك.
وإن لم تكتمل فخر يكفي أن
تعلمنا إذابة الصخري.
(تصفيق)
كان كل شيء يسير على ما يرام وحياة رائعة
إلى أن أتت ألفين وثمانية عشر
أو الوجه الآخر للحياة.
حفل زفاف أختي الذي سيقام خارج البلاد،
وأنا سأبقى في البلاد
لأنني في مرحلة التوجيهي مرحلة مهمة.
وبسبب مشكلة المعابر يجب ألا تخاطر بمستقبلي
لن أرى أختي بإطالتها الملكية
ولن أرى فرحت  أمي بها.
سأكون بين الأوراق أدرس أو أدعي أنني أدرس.
عبرت لهم عن فرحة بالقلوب التي
وفرتها مواقع التواصل.
جرح من جراح الحصار.
يقول محمود درويش “وحدك ولا
أحد يفكر باغتيالك“.
لكن أقول أنا في الطريق وحدي
والجميع يفكر باغتيالي
قبل أن تدخل الاختبار،
حيث تتعالى أصوات الدراسة
تسأل صديقتك
سؤال توجيبك إجابة خاطئة.
يأتي السؤال وتخطئ والوقاحة ألوان
وبعض الناس قوس قزح.
أخبرتني أنها تعمادة الخطأ وهنا
فقدت ثقة بالبشرية.
شكرا لأنك مكارتني.
توفي كل من جَدّ و جدتي رحمهما
الله في نفس الأسبوع.
لكن سنكمل رغم قسوة الفراق
لم ولن نستسلم، سنكمل طريقنا ولو فرادة.
(تصفيق)
لدينا منحة بالخارج.
ذهبت المنحة لتأخر جواز السفر يوم واحد.
شكرا لك يا جواز السفر الذي
لم أستخدم حتى الآن.
والآن بدأ الصراع لدراسة التخصص.
أبي أراد أن أدرس الطب مثله و أمي تريد
الصيدلة على أنها أنسب مهنة للفتاة،
لكن أنا أريد اصترحة من فواجع القدر،
وبالتأكيد لا سلطة تعلو على النساء.
صوت كاظم.
التحقت بكلية الصيدلة بحزن ثقيل.
ففي كل مرة يكون لدي خطة أو هدف.
تفاجئني الحياة بخيبة أمل.
تدريجيا أصبحت أشعر بشعور غامض.
ضباب أسود يحيط بي معتصران، كل طاقتي
أصبحت أشعر بالملل الشديد،
وليس فقط حالة عدم توفيق بضعة أيام وتنتهي،
بل كنت أقول خطابا كيف تكون
اجتماعيا وأنا أخاف من التحدث لأحد
كانت أبسط الأمور تشكل تحديا بالنسبة لي.
كاختيار لون الحقيبة اقف ساعة
حيرة ماذا عساي أن أختار؟
كنت أشعر أنه كابوس،
لكن لا يوجد سبب لأستيقظ منه.
لقد تورطت في هذه المعمعة وانتهى الأمر.
كما جاءه ديسمبر ألفين وثمانية عشر.
هبطت درجات الحرارة وهبطت
طاقتي معدول الصفر.
لاحظ من حولي ذلك.
قالوا الكثير من النصائح لا مفيدة،
لكنني كنت أخبرهم أن كل شيء على ما يرام
لكن لا شيء على ما يرام، ولا بأس أن تكون
الأشياء ليست على ما يرام.
الأهم أن لا يتحول جناحاك
الكبيران إلى عكازين.
قرأت بأحد الكتب.
الجميع اتبع شغفهم بينما أنت جالس على مكتب
تمرد بعد محاولات من الجنون
ومبادرات جادة لتغيير الوضع الراهن.
قررت، قررت التأقلم لأن الدنيا
لم تفصل على مقاسنا بالضبط
ويجب على شاغفينا أن يتبعنا.
وعندما نشعر بإنجاز في أي مجال سنصبح شغوفين
لأن النجاح يدعم الشغف وليس العكس.
فكرت قلت أين أنا و صرخت
لأيقظ نفسي من الهذيان.
وقلت أنا هنا ولي أثر وسيطلع من عتمتي قمر.
(تصفيق)
انتهى ديسمبر ، وفي ديسمبر تنتهي كل الأحلام
، وفي يناير يبدأ حلم جديد.
هكذا قالت الكاتبة أثير عبد الله، فقررت
بدء العام الجديد بقتل العامل الثلاثيني
المدمر لحياة أي شخص وهو أفيودي:
أف فير الخوف الغير مبرر من كل شيء.
يو انسيرتنتي عدم الثقة
بنفسي ولا بالآخرين.
أند داوت الشك بحتمية الوصول
وعلامت أنه مهما تسيدت المراحل
لا بأس بمرحلة تكون بها مزهرية،
لكن عليك أن تكسر قالب المزهرية
وتزهر فلا يهم ماذا يحدث لك.
كل ما يهم ماذا تفعله تجاه ذلك.
فالحياة تحدث لك .
ولأجلك فإن شأته أو أبيت الحياة ستستمر.
يأتي ناس ويذهب آخرون.
نواجه النجاح والفشل.
قد نفقد أصدقاء واحب نتعثر.
نسقط .
لكن على أية حال سنكون على ما يرام.
في إحدى وجبات العشاء قررت مساعدة
والدتي في الأعمال المنزلية،
وبدأت بمساعدتها في تنظيف السمك.
لا تتخيل الحدث عزيز المستمع.
قلت مازحة تخيل أن أجد لؤلؤ في السمك
مثل قصة الصياد واللؤلؤ،
يخبرني أبي أنه قد أجد
بلاستيك بدلا من اللؤلؤ،
توقفت وقلت ماذا؟  لماذا البلاستيك؟
يخبرني أبي عن كارثة البلاستيك
وتأثيره الهائل
بشكل سلبي على عالمنا.
أعددنا العشاء، الجميع يأكل وهو سعيد،
وأنا مازلت عالقة في كلام أبي،
لذلك دائما اجعل أذنيك صاغية.
ابقى مستمعا لأن أي شيء تسمعه ممكن أن
يلهمك ، فقررت البحث أكثر عن مشكلة
البلاستيك التي تشير الإحصائيات
أنها ستدمر عالمنا وبيئتنا.
فبدأت بالأبحاث العلمية.
كنت أعمل أكثر من مئة ساعة
بالأسبوع تطلب مني ذلك السهر حتى الصباح.
الاستيقاظ قبل الجميع.
النوم على الطاولة حتى التحدث مع نفسي.
وسمعت من الكلام أتربة أنك
تضيع وقتك بلا جدوى.
يا خسارة على وقتك و شبابك.
استغله بعمل منطقي ومفيد إلى أن
أكرمنا الله سبحانه وتعالى أن نخترع
The first plantable plastic
.in the world from food waste
(تصفيق)
أول بلاستيك يتحول إلى نبات
مصنوع من بقايا الطعام .
وهناك شيء واحد أقوى من كل جيوش العالم،
وهو الفكرة التي حان وقتها.
أنا رنا وأختي رباب وزملائي خالد زقوت
وإبراهيم السلطان،
شكلنا فريق لا بل شركة
الياقوت الأبيض للبلاستيك.
شاركنا بهذا الاختراع بالهولط
برايز لنتأهل إلى أكبر موسارعت أعمال
ونفوز الأول عالميا بالشوكيس.
(تصفيق)
وكنا دائما بالصدارة ، كما حصلنا على المركز
الأول في تحدي بوصل للإبداع والتميز
ناهيكم عن المؤتمرات العالمية التي شاركنا
فيها وا بحرنا في أجواء الشهرة.
ما أجمله من شعور أنك حقا
تقدم شيئا مختلفا للعالم،
ولأنني لطالما كنت أقترب
بأحمد الأشقر الفلسطيني
الذي ازدهر في عالم الريادة وقاد
أجيالا لجعل عالمنا أفضل،
قررت الالتحاق بإدارة الأعمال
بجانب دراستي للصيدلة
لتنظيم للوقت والمهام، والآن
أنا أبحر في أماكن أحبها
وامتلك صديقات العمر،
و أواجه كل محنة بعين المنحة،
وآمنت أنه حتى يولد منك ذلك النجم الساطع
يجب أن تمتلئ روحك بالفوضى.
أفادني الظنون وأفادني ركدي وراء شغفي.
فعلمت أن المهارة ليست بالقراءة، بل توظيف
ما تقرأ فيالمكان الصحيح،
فعندما تتعدد الخيارات اتبع شغفك بمنطق،
وإذا لم يكن أمامك إلا خيار
واحد فتأكد أنه خير لك وتأقلم.
اتبعت رؤيتي كريدية أعمل
واتبعت رؤية والدتي كصيدلانية
والآن دورك أن تحقق رؤيتك، فكر ماذا لديك؟
كيف يمكنك أن تخدم عالمنا
واختار أن تكون شخصا عاديا
يأكل ويشرب و ينام.
أم تكون لك بصمة لا تنسى.
وإياك وإياك والتردد.
التردد قاتل الفرص.
جازف وعلم ان هناك طريقتان لرؤية الحياة،
لأولى كأنه لا شيء معجزة،
والأخرى كأن كل شيء معجزة.
(تصفيق)
من مدة قصيرة خرجت لمشهدة الشمس
ونظرت للسماء وابتسمت، وجدت نفسي
لم تنسى أثر الكلمات السامة في قلبي،
كما أنني لم أنسى الكلمات التي دعامتين.
قلوبنا أبسط مما نظن.
نتجاوز ونواصل حياتنا بشكل طبيعي
أمام الناس، لكننا لا ننسى
الكليمات، أثرها لا يزول.
إنها أبسط وأقوى سلاح فتاك بالعالم .
لذلك لطفا ، لطفا كن حريصا بانتقاء كلماتك،
أنل ظرتن في هذا
الخطاب وأنتم كل المعادلة
الجمهور العزيز شكرا لأذنكم الصاغية
وشكرا لحضورقم.
(تصفيق)
وما يجعل الخطاب ناجحا أنتم
ورسالة بأيديكم مفعمة بالعبارة الآتية
إذا لم تنهمر دموع الغيوم
كيف ستدحق الطبيعة؟
وكيف يبتسم الاخضرار،
وكيف سترد الزهور؟
و شكرا.
(تصفيق)
شكرا .